[Music]
our scripture today first Corinthians
15:33 do not be deceived bad company
runs good morals
George Washington said it is far better
to be alone than in bad company well
there you go
you do become who you hang around with
you know that right
I was in New York the other day and I
noticed all those people up there have
accents you become who you hang around
with don't you yeah you do
I mean people even even within a certain
area of the country there are different
dialects if you're really attuned to
listening for it you can tell someone
who is born and raised in Middle
Tennessee versus East Tennessee the
dialect is slightly different different
different twang different southern
different sayings yeah you can hear it
it's it you become who you hang around
with did you know your income will
approximate be within 10 to 15 percent
of the average of your 10 closest
friends and come over a period of about
ten years
if you hang out with people who make
good money you won't start to make good
money because you learn to think like
they think you learn to see the world
like they see the world
if you hang out with people who are
victims oh you can't get ahead if you
come from our side of the tracks you
can't get ahead the little man can't get
ahead you hang out with people who er is
there spirit animal yeah you'll be a
victim too
if you hang out you know and I'm serious
because what happens is is it becomes an
echo chamber in a good way you're
hearing back things that you need to
hear over and over and over again like
you can do it or you can't do it and
that's obviously not a good way then so
be careful
choose carefully who you spend time with
now I'm not suggesting you'd be snobby
to someone or I'll talk to anybody
IV I mean III I mean I don't even care
if you're from Kentucky I'll talk to you
I'm kidding all right I'll talk to
anybody
I'll talk to any religion or anything
I'm not gonna argue with you don't allow
you to be belligerent to me about
something but I'll I'll sit down talk to
anybody I'm I love people I like I like
the give-and-take I like the variety of
life I enjoy seeing things and listening
to someone passionately be wrong I I'll
talk to anybody you know I'm fine with
that
that's not what I'm saying I'm not
suggesting you shun people or you're too
good to have a conversation with someone
I don't go over there and that's sort of
the tricks that's not what I'm saying at
all but I'm talking about who your crew
is who your internal circle is your
tightest five or ten people those are
the people that have influence in your
life your speech patterns will
approximate them you will watch the same
movies and read the same books you will
develop eventually the same belief
systems and value systems if they go to
church you will if they read the Bible
you will if they pray you will if
they're improving their character you
will if they are working out and taking
care of their body you will if they're
watching their food intake you will
the closest five or ten people that you
spend the most time with that you can
sit was going to carry your casket those
six people that's who I'm talking about
ones that are in your life your crew
your Posse whatever you want to call it
you're gonna be like them you cannot
keep it from happening do not be
deceived bad company runs good morals
1st Corinthians 15:33 George Washington
said it is far better to be alone than
in bad company if you hang out with
whining victims you will begin to see
the world through the eyes of whining
victims
if you hang out with triumphant victors
you will begin to see the world through
the eyes of triumphant victors people
who are victorious
they're champions they're what we call
successful in whatever area of life that
is you want to emulate and cause that to
happen
now again I'm more than happy to talk to
anyone but I'm talking about who I spend
enough time with that they influence
everything down to my speech patterns we
know this because we don't allow our
children to run around with juvenile
delinquents because our children will
become a juvenile delinquent if little
Johnny down the streets a weed head your
kid runs around with little Johnny your
kids gonna be a weed head that maybe
that's okay with you
that's not my value system I didn't want
to raise weed hits so we didn't let our
kids run around with weed heads pretty
simple hitting it you're gonna become
who you hang around with you're gonna
become who you hang around with shoes